wer bei shampoo
jede seite
er weiß schon heute wogen sind immer
wieder alles neu beginnt
wir sind heute in garmisch partenkirchen
geburtsstätte von michael ende ein
großer deutscher schriftsteller der
unter anderem die unendliche geschichte
geschrieben hat oder wo und die jungs
von meiner band von 16 spielen bei einem
theaterstück welches heute stattfinden
wird
mit und das ganze schutzmacht das ist
nämlich der michael ende kurpark
er ist wie der name schon sagt für
michael ende gebaut worden und ist sehr
verspielt verträumt wie seine
geschichten eben auch hier sind was kann
ich mir denn hier so anschauen was
wirklich einmalig ist michael ende und
so michael ende
aber wir sind auch hier michael ende
kurpark aufgeschnappte spielt die
schauspielerin schon rum sind quasi
schon ihren rollen finden sich schon
kannst du mir was über michael ende
sagen ich versuche die irgendwie
abzuholen das du irgendwas erzählen
können über michael endler irgendwie
sind die schon in der michael ende welt
das hoffen auf eine
17 ich daher eine chance nochmal weiter
da ist michael ende ein
riesenschildkröten liebhaber und
bestimmt auch großer zeitfresser
sie mir sagen gehabt zu dieser
geschichte passiert hinter sind unsere
natürlichen feinden sie lassen sich nur
sehr viel schwerer zu zeit sparen
bringen als erwachsene menschen
überweisen
da will ich nicht mehr in solchen massen
waren lauter gitter an den fenstern und
jeden tag gab es prügel
dann will ich nicht mehr hin
bestehen
ihr beim spielen wir natürlich alle
möglichen sachen wir sind ein paar
musiker von 16 sind mich alle dabei aber
wir haben hier unsere ganze effekt kiste
aufgebaut wenn er irgendwie die zeit
machen dann irgendwie auf alle möglichen
sachen damit die zeit oder wir haben
ihren sound schuldig wenn die grauen
herren kommen das ist auch irgendwie
ganz spannend das geht hat sowieso nicht
die geringste chance zu entkommen
als ich versuche zu noch jemand an
diesem grauen herren zu erreichen weil
wir immer so problem mit unserem
probezeiten haben und da wir effizient
arbeiten möchten frage jetzt einfach mal
die profis eine minute und 60 sekunden
gehöre eine stunde hat 60 minuten 60 mal
60 es 3600 mal 24 stunden 365 tage macht
30 millionen 536.000 sekunden pro jahr
oder 315 millionen 360.000 sekunden
ziehen
und wenn ich da jetzt zeit an spare dann
das überlasse ich uns